Donald Trump was so triggered by Chris
Christie's Town Hall during which Chris
Christie attacked Trump on issues on
facts on deficit on Ukraine right like
not doing the anti-woke stuff Trump was
so triggered
that he went after Chris Christie
because Chris Christie is obese
but Trump is obese
and this is quite a double standard that
I want to talk about Donald Trump
posting to his platform truth essential
quote how many times did Chris Christie
use the word small does he have a
psychological problem with size actually
his speech was small and not very good
it rambled all over the place and nobody
had a clue of what he was talking about
hard to watch boring but that's what you
get from a failed Governor New Jersey
who left office with a seven percent
approval rating and then got run out of
New Hampshire this time it won't be any
different Trump then posting a
photoshopped picture of Chris Christie
from yesterday's Town Hall photoshopped
to put Chris Christie at a buffet with
all sorts of different foods in front of
him look I can't even identify what
these foods are looks like maybe some
kind of Italian-American food or
something like that hard to hard to
actually see
um so Trump just basically using fat
jokes against Chris Christie
um I continue to not understand
how it is
that Trump isn't being called out for
the fact that he makes fun of other
people's weight but Trump is obese Trump
is obese yes he has figured out ways to
disguise it and yes Chris Christie is
more obese than Donald Trump but
remember there's this whole story where
Trump claims to be six foot three and
239 pounds which quite literally puts
him one pound away from technically
being obese according to BMI BMI is not
a perfect measure by any means but it
gives us some some idea but we know that
that's not true we know that Trump isn't
as tall as he says and it's very obvious
that Trump is much heavier than he
claims to be and if you even adjust his
height by an inch or his weight by a
pound he becomes obese if you look at
pictures of trump next to Obama they
look to be roughly the same height we
know Obama's only six one not six three
at 239 that makes Trump obese we know
that there are pictures of trump with
former baseball player Alex Rodriguez we
know A-Rod is 6'3 and he looks way
taller than Trump and so if we assume
Trump is actually 6-1 instead of six
three unless Trump is 200 pounds or
under he's obese and you look at Trump
and it's very obvious that he's not 40
pounds lighter than he claims to be he's
somewhere between 10 and 30 pounds
heavier than he claims to be so I say
all of this
to remind you
that Trump is obese but he makes fun of
Chris Christie's weight and part of this
comes from the magical thinking that is
not based in reality that his followers
fall for yeah Trump is right Chris
Christie's fat so he would be a bad
president but the guy you support is
also fat yeah but that's different
that's totally different or he's not
actually fat he's not obese or they're
lying about this or they're lying about
that how does an obese guy get away with
making fun of everybody else's weight I
don't understand it and I'm going to
have one more clip about this because
there's actually another element to this
story
are you tired of getting crushed in the
market or the volatility there is some
good news which is that treasury yields
are surging you can now get a whopping
five percent yield on treasury bills
that is higher than any high yield
savings account that I have seen but
buying U.S treasuries can be a
complicated process at least it used to
be that's where our sponsor public.com
comes in with public you can buy
treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone couldn't be easier plus
public will even automatically roll over
your Investments at maturity so you have
one less thing to think about take
another thing off your plate treasury
bills are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
out there and when you buy them through
public they are securely stored at the
Bank of New York Mellon which is the
largest custodian Bank in the world no
minimum hold periods no settlement
delays you have full access to your
funds whenever you need them put your
cash to work earn at five percent yield
by going to public.com Pacman don't miss
the opportunity the link is down below